Ros 17. Ros 17. This is what it was all
about right from the very beginning.
This is what it was about for this guy.
Oh, this is so embarrassing. Oh, this
needs to be documented. Make sure you
archive this stream. This needs to be
documented. This is the weirdest,
grossest I've ever seen. Destiny so
upset about this. He's doxing people.
That makes him the real victim. Oh my
god. Pisco wouldn't EVEN SAY THAT
DESTINY'S NOT a He's totally starf
brain. We have to destroy him.
>> [music]
>> Who is Pisco talking to? I believe he's
talking to the usurp guy. Hold on. Usurp
the chef. He's talking to this guy. You
remember the guy who did the video where
he's like throwing things into his mouth
while talking to Hassan?
>> Hey son, how you doing?
I'm happy I was finally able to wake you
out of your slump cuz for a while you
had your pants on and you were just too
afraid to have any conversations with
people that disagree with you. But I
noticed at the beginning of your stream
today you said you kind of wanted to
switch that up and maybe have some
conversations with some of these people.
And since well since I triggered the
ever loving [__] out of you today, I'll
throw my hat in a ring.
>> This guy was trying to shoot on Pisco
and this guy
this guy is talking to Pisco right now.
This guy thinks Hassan is like going to
overthrow the government. This guy's one
of the Yeah, this guy's this guy's a big
DJ
>> in the first place and presumably but
that's true that to be true but not
everybody else not everybody else he's
talking about the broader audience the
people that don't know
>> but the specific
>> the epste
aspect of it raises other concerns
regarding the unhingedness of proposing
that hypothetical
>> that isn't shown by
>> wouldn't it have been better like Hassan
or JD Vance
It shows you you think Hassan is worse
than Jeffrey Epstein. THAT'S WHAT IT
SHOWS YOU.
>> THAT'S WHAT IT SHOWS YOU.
>> What is you did when you said I
[laughter]
over tell me what is Jeffrey Epstein's
policy platform.
>> Dude, [laughter] you don't need That's a
fair question, isn't it? Isn't that
relevant to the analysis? I don't know
anything about Jeffrey Epstein's
politics.
Would he push for a public option?
Is he a Medicare for all kind of person?
I don't know anything about his
politics. The reason why I would not
necessarily disqualify Jeffrey Epstein
electorally is because first we would
have to establish if he supports liberal
democracy. Because the whole thing with
Hassan is that he doesn't. And I had
people in my own chat last night that
thought I was being ridiculous. I don't
wh how why am I being ridiculous when
we're talking about Hassan [__] These
guys talk to millions and millions and
millions of people. They only get 30 or
40 on their live streams, but you also
have to remember that you have their
fans who then take those clips and show
it to their friends who might not be
watching those streams.
>> That's why I think it's really good to
try to convince people in their audience
who might be on the fence. And I think
one way to do that is not to wholesale
ban them from our communities all the
time on the basis of their views.
>> Do you think that's irrational for me to
take that position?
>> Hey, maybe a way to reach these people
is to convince them. And maybe you don't
convince them by doing a purge of all
communists.
>> I can I can see that. I can see that.
Like
>> isn't that like kind of approach that
Mach is taking here where he's like
trying to build a bridge with Come on.
Let's be honest. He's building a bridge
with Assan. He's being nice to
>> I think he he the fact that he repeated
the same questions three times and got
Assan to say three different answers.
>> Yeah, but he was nice and he was nice.
He gave him outs. He gave him outs. He
didn't push the way I would have pushed
>> you and you can push. What I'm saying is
it's it's not that fate or shows that
I'm a sweeper for tankies that I don't
ban them on the basis of their ideology.
One of the reasons why I don't like to
do that is because I like to debate them
and I like to I feel like I own them
sometimes and I feel like I do well in
those conversations.
>> No, you do. Yeah. The last time you talk
to Ogre Boy, you [__] [__] all over
them.
>> Okay, but like if I just ban them
wholesale from the community, like what
does that accomplish?
>> And maybe if I said that you should ban
them all.
>> Entirely spitebased position from
Destiny. Pisco literally has the same
ideas that Destiny had 3 years ago on
how you deal with like extremist
political ideologies or just people you
disagree with in general. This is an
entirely spite-based position about
Hassan specifically that Destiny just
came up with because he hates that
Hassan's way more popular than him.
That's all. Okay. It's totally
discordant with all beliefs he's
espoused in the past. It's such a joke
right away at the beginning. I I would I
don't think I actually believe
>> you don't debate them in your chat says
this.
>> Sorry. And I talk about I talk about
Destiny because obviously this who's
talking to Pisco right now is just
espousing Destiny's beliefs. He doesn't
have any of his own.
>> Of course you debate them in the chat.
Maybe you don't tune into the stream
enough. I pull out I have this the thing
the system that lets me pull up messages
and all the time I yell left these in
the chat. Anyone who's here regularly
will see me do that. No, you don't.
Okay, I scroll. No, like I I do that and
um I don't just do it. I do it for mega.
>> There was like a a chatter in your chat.
Now again, this is weird, but like
sometimes you think there's like obvious
examples where it's like someone has
this. You should probably just ban this.
>> ROS 17. ROS 17.
>> And like and that includes not only just
commies and stuff.
>> Bring it up. Bring it up. Bring it up.
>> Um the um
>> that's it, right? That's the real
>> why would you think I about that? Why do
you keep I take the viewer appealing to
appealing to communist explain why
you're actually here IT
>> OH PISCO SHUT UP AND LET THE GUY TALK
he's about to say something he's about
to say something incredibly embarrassing
>> from a stream maybe that's engaging is
better
>> do you think right away or you think of
people that have been slow or that have
been over time saying the same things
constantly on liberals
>> in your chat community in your chat of
>> I don't think anyone's ever made a
distinction between constant and versus
do it one time
>> I've never heard that people come in
comes in every liberals.
>> Yeah. And guess what? I have a very um
nice set of conversations that I've had
with him where I push back on it and
>> and there could be a world where there
could be a world where in a year and a
half your community is 40%
>> uh Yeah, we said this. We said this.
Yes,
>> exactly.
>> I don't I don't even know if that were
the case. Are you going to say that I
would be corrupted and I would like
start?
>> No, I know. I would just say it it would
just be then another place where we have
a chat room with a liberal streamer base
liberal streamer whose entire audience
is is doing infighting all the time and
we're
>> Hey, hey, hey, Pisco, have you thought
about how you should just be loyal to
Destiny? Okay, I'm seeing that's his
actual problem. And this guy probably
knows to some extent that he can't just
say that. What I actually want to clean
up is not the communists. I like when
people own communists. I don't want the
anti- Destiny people here. People who
don't like Destiny, you have to you have
to get rid of them. People who don't
like certain streamers, you have to get
rid of them.
>> We're fighting and we're trying to like
give a home to these arsonists.
>> Like these guys have bed bugs all over
them and we're just letting them in.
We're wondering why we're rich.
>> Like Mockler [clears throat] is.
>> No, I don't think that.
>> I think Mler did a very good job making
Hassan look
>> like like I do with Ogre, right?
>> Yeah. But again, if Mach was I don't
think that Hassan would allow cuz he's
not dumb. He wouldn't allow Mockler and
his whole crew to be in his chat.
>> Wait, does Pisco not know that Adam
Mockler has seen like people in his
chat? He said to Hassan, I've seen
people in my chat say things like this
and I think that's like people around
you like, "Oh, you can't vote for
Kamala."
>> Because he knows even even Hassan knows
that if he let too many bass ass
liberals in his chat that it would with
him it would make his projective
against people watch agree with it.
>> It's honestly
>> I think that's if you had uh remember
like old vulletin like those old web
forms.
>> Okay, you just because that is boring to
me. I like people who disagree with me
and in fact
>> having only people who agree with me in
the chat is boring and it would
inevitably lead to me just like
disagreement libs all the time. But
you've got to understand that people are
going to people have a different view at
this and it seems that since these
lefties are so good at infiltrating all
these communities all the time that like
when you see these communities um are
>> where they're so good at infiltrating
all these communities they're literally
just chatters who like Pisco like that
Pisco is a more by the way not all of
these people that they refer to are
leftists a lot of them are liberals who
just don't like the community that this
guy comes from and so they laugh at that
community but they are just liberals
that's why they watch Pisco because they
want their liberal opinions validated.
constantly on liberals all the time and
then what happens at the end you have
them in your community
hopefully you can bring them on to our
side but then at the end of the day no
matter who the candidate is they're
going to vote third party or something
>> on that view should ban every single
person who's doing harsh critics of me
>> I'm a bas liberal I'm supporting people
who are vote [snorts] for the candidate
this is live on the violence so he
should know
>> uh no because he has a personal right
now
>> oh so that obviousates right because of
course there's a personal person
[laughter] being yeah no but in terms of
justification in terms of justification
you say personal beef obviousates the uh
constant harsh snark criticism of Well,
I think he would probably see that you
like have a chatter in your chat a lot
called Rose was 17. And he would
probably look at that and be like, "Why
would Pisco my friend not ban somebody
like that from my chat room?" He might
take that as like a personal, you know,
>> uh, how about cuz Pisco is trying to say
he's not looking into this, right? Pisco
literally said he's not looking into
this. Pisco doesn't want to take a side.
If he bans that guy, he has to take a
position. He has to have a reason for
banning him. He loses all predicate for
not discussing the case.
>> Attack a strong word. It's like, man,
that doesn't feel good to me.
was my friend and this guy also this guy
has this person in their chat.
>> Yeah. the position is that I should take
a substantive view on an issue and a set
of issues where I have said for reasons
that sometimes even in your to even's
benefit um that and also relate to
ethics that um I would necessarily have
to get involved there because I have to
take a view on that right in favor of
destiny right
>> if you still considered him a friend
right
>> no stop with this is that the case or
not is is the position that
>> dude this it's so gay these people are
so transparent thank you thank you usurp
the chef thank you for coming in and
doing this and making it so obvious what
your actual goal is what you're actually
doing here. Okay, you come and you're
like, well, if you were still a friend,
>> dude, it's so embarrassing, man. You
people are so embarrassing.
>> Well, because I am not venturing into
this um subject that is of the lawsuit
and related issues, for good reasons,
for reasons that make sense, for reasons
that are honorable and not dishonorable,
for those reasons on others um that
>> I'm necessarily now subject to endless
infinite snark even though I'm a base
slip.
>> That's No, I don't think that's that's
not what I said, though. Do you want me
to ban people?
>> You not covering it is a good thing. You
not like I can understand your position.
You're like, listen, it's a messy
situation. It's going on court. And I
would imagine maybe, again, I'm not a
lawyer. I don't know if there's any kind
of like ethical things that you
shouldn't comment on ongoing cases. If
that's a thing that makes sense. I don't
know. But like you guys were friends of
>> people People People think I talked to
Pisco. This is what convinces Pisco that
that community is not something you want
to engage with. Right. People think I
talk to Pisco. I don't talk to Pisco. I
don't have to say anything to Pisco.
Just DJ's interacting with other
communities is enough for them to find
that community disgusting. Thank you
guys.
>> There's no better starker against DGG
than just some DGER going and joining
someone's VC. Thank you so much.
>> Together in New York. Um and you I think
you not covering it, you not going into
all the the drama and like reading all
the documents when they come out. I
think that's a good thing because
>> you know it's not your place. It's not
your business. But at the same
to see somebody in his chat in your chat
called Rose was 17 and he might look at
that be like damn why is he not deleting
that person? That's kind of [__] up.
>> I understand I understand he might think
that but the question is like what do
you think I should do? I mean probably
just like if any like in that one
scenario probably ban somebody like
that.
>> In other words, take a stance in favor
of Destiny in the ongoing issues. That
is what you want them to do. That is
>> I think that is just that is taking a
stand at a level that no one would judge
you on. And I think that's a stance that
most people would agree with
>> because even if you want to remain
neutral having somebody having like the
reason that chat
>> stance that nobody I like to imply that
Destiny's a pedophile.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Do you believe Dest
is related to and you're not going to
bait me? No, I'm just I don't think you
think that. I do not think you think
that. I don't think you think that
you're supposed not going to come.
>> Oh my god. PISCO WOULDN'T EVEN SAY THAT
DESTINY'S not a He's totally dark brain.
We have to destroy him,
>> right? Right. So, you understand? Do you
understand the issue with me
>> taking a stance in terms of what I
comment on?
>> It's so transparent. It's so
transparent. This is what it was all
about, right? From the very beginning,
this is what it was about for this guy.
It was about, hey, that people say mean
things about Destiny and I really don't
like that and I want you. This guy is
saying all the gay, embarrassing,
humiliating [__] that Destiny refused to
say cuz he knows it's embarrassing. He
knows it's humiliating to go to another
creator and get on your knees and ask
for this, right? He knows how
embarrassing it looks. So, this guy is
doing it for him. Wow. And then you
delete that person without commenting.
You say, "Hey, I don't let I don't I
don't allow accusations of pedophilia of
people being in my chat without
evidence." And I don't like that kind of
[__] My
>> for example, was a friend of mine
commenting on his case.
I just wish could could is anyone going
to ask this guy wait how old Ros
for example Ethan Klein or Hassan or any
other No I'm to get involved in all
these different disputes and and there's
new rule no uncredible accusations
>> yeah but I guess maybe you didn't have
the relationship with those people with
with Destiny that's the difference
>> yeah so what you're proposing right what
you're proposing is uh empathetic rule a
protective rule that's special a special
rule for Destiny correct
>> yes
>> you don't actually believe what you're
saying now do you
>> I do believe what I'm saying. I'm asking
you a question.
>> Like you think that this in your mind if
you saw somebody who's like um what if
they were making fun of his son, would
you allow that in your chat?
>> I if they were making
>> like um Nathan um Destiny bad dad to
Nathan, would you allow that in your
chat?
>> I don't think that you know any kind of
accusation towards minors. Um I don't
know that I would allow.
>> Well, that's what this is.
>> No, but that's not an accusation. That's
not an accusation about a minor. That's
an accusation about the stream.
>> I think it's I think it's one of the
>> It's also not an accusation about the
minor. The minor was 17. They were a
minor.
>> Honestly, I think [laughter] that it is.
Wait, this is this is like this is like
the probably the most blacking part of
this conversation for me. like in my
mind um because I think it's what I'm
asking or what the question I'm trying
to pose is is is is pretty simple like
you can not want to talk about him. You
can not want to cover the case. You can
do all that but it's not murky. It's
only murky in that like basically
Destiny doesn't like that somebody does
that to imply he's a right I've never
called Destiny a for those pictures.
I've said he retained pictures of that
person when they were a minor obviously.
So like video of them when they're a
minor and anybody who retains
you know for most of the internet they
would call that guy a okay there's
there's a way you work to it but it's
not to saying Destiny was impro like
destiny thinking this person was 19 or
whatever and getting nudes from them by
the way knew the person a week had no
identifi identity verification at all
and still kept talking to them in a way
that totally contradicts the own advice
he's given other creators his own advice
he's given other creat
so many words and you saying like oh
Banning that person means I would be
commenting on the case.
>> I don't think you believe that. That
would just be someone say, "Hey, I don't
like you accusing former friends of
mine. We might not even talk today, but
it if I ban this person, you think if I
ban it, will all of the snarking of
there is right?"
>> Oh, sorry. You kind of cut up there.
>> Do you believe there's snarking going
on?
>> Snarking of you.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. If I ban this, you think?
>> Wait. All I heard is if I ban this
person as mic is cutting out.
>> Um, no. Oh, that's not
>> But I don't think that you should ban
that and hoping for something and and
hope for something in return. I I would
I if I was in your position, I would do
that because that was something I would
want to do. I don't expect anything in
return.
>> You're half correct in the following.
>> Here's how you're correct. You're
correct in the sense that none of this
is about communism.
>> All of that. No, none of it. Absolutely
zero of it. And the reason you're lost,
homie.
>> No. No. I'm telling you that none of it
has to do. Absolutely none of it. I'm
back out. Testing one, two, three.
Hello.
>> Yeah. What's Yeah. Sorry. Is that
better?
>> None of it.
>> Go. Pisco sees it. He sees through the
matrix. piss goes off the plantation
>> [__] communism and that was aboutism
right doesn't have to do about because
people can make reasonable decisions
about what is the best way to influence
good people and no sane person no sane
person thinks that I'm turning into a
communist that's that's an insane thing
to say even in the area
>> I don't think anyone's even saying that
>> then why would I be speaking for them
>> for money
opinions change opinions
>> if you think that this the way to grow
an audience is to you know sometimes
take stances you know principally that
happen to favor lives and sometimes take
stances that principally happen to favor
communist sometimes or socialist
whatever on the TSA thing, double the
entry thing. It's not It's not the best
way to grow an audience to pick a
[__] lane. That's obviously the best
way to pick the This isn't helping me. I
lose subs over this. Every every time
Hutch, by the way, it's usually not me
bringing up these conflicts. Every time
this It's usually like Hutch bringing in
lefties to talk to, which I'm fine with
because I'm just going to give my
authentic take no matter what. And I'm
just going to tell how I see it. But
it's not like I'm bringing in the
lefties to like poison everybody. It's
just I'm reacting, having the person
you're doing that either. I think that
people think that people like you a
piece. Like before everything happened,
you were like what? You were buddy of
the year, right?
>> No, I I didn't you would be in content,
right? Like you were you were great.
Like every pisto
>> Pisco just take care of just scratch
Destiny's back and then we'll scratch
yours Pisco. Hey Pisco this is this is
the classic Trump move right here. We're
you want this to go good or bad for you?
Cuz I'm you. Do you want it to go good
or bad? Which which way do you want it
to go?
>> Let him piss like changed. So have I
changed? I haven't changed. I haven't
changed. I You think I changed? What
have I changed on? Honestly, I I don't
know much that you have changed on to be
honest. However, this community switched
and obviously Destiny's personal
feelings. I'm not going to speak for
them because I don't know them. But what
I think is that you whether and I might
be wrong.
>> You don't know them. Do you really not
know them or are you just are you just
your feelings are Destiny's feelings.
You have Destiny's feelings imprinted on
you. You don't have your own brain
waves. Your your brain waves have been
rewritten with Destiny's brain waves.
Okay.
>> In this judgment or in my in my thought
here, you might be trying extra hard to
get out of his shadow. And not I'm not
trying to say this insulting way or let
me explain this. Not honest to god I'm
not trying like you don't want to be
pisco the guy who used to be on destiny
stream and not not hide the lawsuit
because you want to be around that makes
sense right
>> I'm not embarrassed by my past I'm not
embarrassed like destiny and I lie more
on politics and of course it made sense
that for us to like to be collaborating
I had there's a reason why I came to you
to to set this [__] up I'm not
embarrassed by because what I thought I
was doing was um helping the country
helping you know promote liberal values
and uh instead of what I think is more
cringe kind of deadender socialism on
some channels and so I don't I'm not
like embarrassed by by that [__] like
that's not the case right I'm not trying
to the same embarrass [laughter]
Embarrass had nothing to do with it. It
was more like nobody wants to any any
guy in his own career doesn't want to be
tied to somebody else who was who he was
with in the beginning
>> flaws and all. I mean, you know, yeah, I
I think it's kind of like silly,
especially because I don't go out of my
way to critique Destiny or go attack
him. It's the opposite. I realize that,
right? It's the opposite. I don't think
you do. It's literally the opposite. So,
I I get seen clips where it's like he's
ascribing that I'm doing this for money.
Oh, peace knows what he's doing here.
It's not going to really like the reason
doing that cuz like
it's the most malicious obsessive I
might say ascribing of malice to me. I'm
not going out of my way to go disagree
with him and go get under his that
couldn't be farther from the truth.
>> Listen listen he's probably really all
stressed out. Listen how I can't imagine
what I would be going through what I
would be thinking of other people if I
was in the middle of a crazy ass lawsuit
if I have I'm not saying you did this.
I'm not saying you did this, but if I
had lost all of my
This is so embarrassing. Oh, this needs
to be documented. Make sure you archive
this stream. This needs to be
documented. This is the weirdest,
grossest I've ever seen. He's just in
here. Can't you just think about the
real victim here? Destiny so upset about
this. He's doxing people. That makes him
the real victim. my friends or people
that I thought were my friends and no
one wanted to talk to me and everybody
at the very beginning they thought I was
like they automatically assumed the
>> oh this guy's so lucky this guy is so
lucky that Pisco has taken a principled
stance against commenting oh yeah since
the very beginning wait what changed
from the allegations at the very
beginning what what's changed at all
nothing literally the only thing we know
is that he's admitted to doing the exact
thing he was accused of doing from the
beginning
>> party the other party and they thought I
was this this monster. Like I would be
angry and suspicious and and attacking.
>> I would have a short
>> I would be I would be I'd be lashing out
at everybody and I might perceive like
certain actions in a certain way whether
that be right or wrong. And I feel like
you have to understand that as well. No,
like that's at least that's
>> I'm not going out of my way to
antagonize him or DGG. I'm not doing
that. I'm not going through my community
and banning DGers. There was a guy
there's a there's a member of our
community. Um although keep in mind that
DG has a special rule in my community.
No one else gets this except for Ethan
Klein. No Destiny related drama on the
Discord. Already a special protection.
I'm sure there's no rule like that for
Pisco in any Discord or community or
whatever. Already special protection for
them. But even putting that aside, there
was um a value I'm not even going to out
right now, but a valid member of the
community who appeared on Destiny and
was doing something really great and we
were all super encouraging and like
proud of this person. And it's not like
I'm going out of my way to be like, "Oh,
you shouldn't interact." Like that's
never you know I know that Hutch and um
Soy Pill and I desa have they have I
said don't interact with Destiny don't
no instead what has actually happened is
a complete mischaracterization which I
can only take as bad faith for many
different reasons
>> double my intention that my intention is
either money to ingratiate myself with
people various different people to oh
he's touch my co-host
>> by the Hey, the reason Destiny continues
to go after Pisco is because Pisco is a
better option to be like a liberal
influencer online. He's better at
debating. He's better at researching.
He's more focused. He's not got the
baggage. And if Pisco rises,
Destiny diminishes. There's nothing that
you would want in Destiny stream that
you couldn't get from a Pisco stream if
your goal is politics. Pisco will take
every serious political person from
Destiny. Destiny boot will be left with
just being Ethan Ralph. That's the only
thing he'll have left. Every serious
principled interested like like advocate
that exists will go to Pisco over
Destiny. And that is why Destiny has to
attack him repeatedly and try to
denigrate his reputation. Try to
denigrate him and his reputation because
Pisco is just better in every way for
serious politics. I by the way I would
think, you know, in terms of being
funny, if you look at Desi from like
2021, Desi is way funnier than Pisco is
now. But in terms of actual serious
political drive debating polit political
subjects it's not close. Pisco is
better.
>> And did Hush say he felt my
>> Yeah, a little bit. But no, but but that
were my intent. [laughter] I'm sorry.
>> No, but as though that were my intent,
which of course it's not. Why would I
want to do that?
>> I don't know. Why does he feel that
>> suck up to socialists?
>> Why there's a reason Hutch feels that
way, dog?
>> Yeah. Well, I think that possible that
he he thinks that I'm just trying to
[__] with him at some elements. I think
that he was I pressed him on the answer
to that. The actual answer here that
Pisco doesn't want to say is no. I see
who's in Hutch's chat, too. I see who's
in Hutch's chat. You think we couldn't
do this, by the way? Go find all of the
people who are like trying to get Hutch
to go after Pisco and tie them all back.
I could, if I had the time, I could
easily do this. Okay, I could very
easily do this. I don't have the time
like some other people, right? And so,
you know, perhaps, but I don't think
Hutch thinks that I'm sweeping for
tankies just to do it. What would
explain my behavior with ogre? You know,
you don't get friends for being
perceived as defense.
>> Easy target dog.
>> No, dude. Well, but the thing is I don't
withhold criticism.
>> Over half [__] bro. Like, you think
I hold criticism of Assan?
>> It's like punching a fat. What?
>> You think I hold criticism of Assan or
any other lefty?
>> No, [laughter]
I just don't understand it. Like, it
really is to me.
>> Listen, I think there's it's it's
>> You don't think that I'm doing this
because you said I'm a base lib. You
said I'm you know, it's sad because I'm
like I don't know a lib podcast even
though that's not my goal. And usually
when we're fighting, it's about the best
way to implement liberal strategy,
right? It's like and most of the time I
just want to let you know the majority
of the panel agrees with me. You
understand that like in all these
discussions on the shutdown on the
nature of Chuck Schumer stepping down on
what we just said about the
hypotheticals with Assan versus other
>> politicians in a hypothetical matchup
I'm in the majority of the panel whether
that was a econom boy or whether now
it's in the majority and so the special
that's another way that you know it's
bad faith like has the same opinion I do
>> of Assan [__] the exact same and no one
says well he's covering up for tankies
when he expresses that opinion no one we
had a discussion with Hutch and Jaziah
where we were just saying the same thing
all of the entity is towards
It doesn't make sense because it's not
premised on these issues. These are
these are just pretexts.
>> But if so many people have this feeling
and and so many people that you consider
your friends have this feeling, do you
think there's no like mass psychosis?
>> Like do you think that's just it's only
mass psychosis
>> and lies? I mean take the issue just of
global entry, right? Global entry or
something that is a liberal issue,
right? About
somebody signed up for YouTube with the
name Pisco's girlfriend was 17.
Apparently
>> viewpoint discrimination. And
>> by the way, that's that's even that's
worse. That's an outright lie, right?
That's just an outright lie. So that
would be open to I I assume being
banned.
>> No, no, no, no, no. I I believe he lied
too about some aspects of it. But Dustin
and I agree. I have a clip of him saying
that he was likely because of uh things
he said about Rick Scott and other
things, but at least on those based
facts, there's an agreement. Now,
there's an interpretive question about
well, if it were based on these
statements or the Houthi interview or
anything like that, if it were based on
that, would that be problematic? But
that's not a factual dispute. That's
like a a legal interpretive dispute. But
that issue was used where I'm basically
saying, "Yeah, the administration which
before has discriminated in the first
term on global entry and which has
discriminated in this term on global
entry for other people too as well as
every other aspect of immigration.
They're checking social media accounts
in the same month in which this the
Hassan um deauthorization for global
entry came down all this stuff at the
same time that in that context if I take
a position this is bad. I actually think
it's you know they was put in
discrimination. What what [laughter] the
how is that communist sweeping?" That's
not me saying anything like that. you
know, the settler baby conversation
would taken so out of context calling
Hassan deplorable for not condemning his
friends. And I'm just saying he's not
literally advocating for baby here. He's
saying it's would be legally
permissible. He's wrong about and that's
wrong for its own sake. But it's it's
it's no because he doesn't tell a lie.
The lie would be that he's advocating
for babies to be killed.
>> That therefore I'm s for tanks and I'm
only watching that video because it was
requested,
>> right? Right. So the fact that I'm
engaging with you right now, you know,
the fact that I bother to do like the
probably ignore all this like the easy
thing for me to do would just be banan
references to Destiny, ban references to
Hassan from my chat and focus on law and
focus on live stuff. Do you Zia does
that would be the easy way out?
>> I mean, would you be willing to speak
with him? I
>> I've already spoke with him two times.
Of course I would be.
>> All right. Would you be like let's uh
let's bring him in. I think I saw him in
a way earlier.
>> Yeah, but like is do you think
>> but you've been asking a lot of like I'm
speaking as like an outside
>> I Pisco needs to just say here. Okay.
Yeah. Oh, we got to get Desie in here.
Pisco needs to say, I talked to Destie
about this. He had no recommendations.
He's just going to come in here and
virtue signal. He's going to try to make
me look bad. It is not a good faith
conversation. It is not a good faith
conversation at all. He should not talk
to the person.
>> And and he like you were asking me why
do you think he was saying calling you
um or saying at least I'm I'm happy. I'm
afraid of no man.
>> Are you willing to cringe that I'm not
doing this because of communism or
because I'm shooting for tankies or
because I want to hurt huts or because I
want to make money.
>> I do not I don't think I'll let you
know. If I wanted to make money and
maximize making money, I wouldn't do
this. I left the job where I was making
a lot of money. No, don't ask me. I have
seen you're doing it because of money.
>> I told I told everybody this like the
idea that Pisco is doing this for money
in like the short term. The only way
Pisco is doing this for money is by
building something like out of concrete,
right? He is making like the parthonon.
That's the only way he is making money
here. He was like in
he's hit a he's making a lot of money.
Okay. He was making a lot of lot of
money.
>> I don't think you're doing it just
because of the money. But Ubie has
>> he's just building something slowly over
time. He is not going to cash in his
stream or his reputation for anything
cheap
>> like $1,000 or maybe maybe at this point
overall like $900. He's given more to
Connor. You understand that?
>> Is banned from my Discord. Maybe is
banned from my Discord. If I wanted to
make money, I wouldn't do this. Like I
said, I don't think it might just be
>> Destiny is seething in his chat right
now about not being able to get you
might have complete perfect contentions,
but other people just think differently.
It could just go all the way down to
that. People have a different view of
what's better or what the better action
would be. But
>> like the money thing just makes no
sense. Like
>> and I think that's a small part of it.
But like honestly like I never said it
was about money. That's what Destiny
said. So I would bring him up and talk
with him about that.
>> I might just do that. But um I think
we're cool, right? I mean do you have
any problem with me?
>> No, I don't have any problem with you.
You were the one like, "Hey man, when I
first came in I was like, "Hey man, why
are you so hot?"
>> I was doing a bit. I was doing a bit.
>> I know. But you say you weren't doing a
bit.
>> That's part of the bit.
>> It's bits on bits on bit. No, of course
I like I want I want you to be a huge
streamer one day, bro. Like you're
entertaining, you're smart, you're
funny. Like, but like I also think that
when people maybe criticize you,
>> it's it's coming from a place like it
might be a little spicy. It's emotional.
I think it's emotional.
>> It's emotional because they like you.
>> Well, I don't know. I mean, you guys
were friends for a while. So, unless all
that was fake, let's all that was a bit
too.
>> No, I mean the sad part is, right, like
here's here's a little secret, right?
way to totally make me pick the DG to
make me like angry is to like lie on me.
That's like a very very easy way to get
me to be like that. People lie on me.
>> That is like probably not a good
strategic move to like I'll tell you who
hasn't done that. The lefties. Now,
because I'm principled, I'm not going to
like become a lefty because they're nice
to me. But the people who have lied to
me aren't lefties. Not me.
>> Cuz they're trying to get in. They're
brats.
>> Well, and just in terms of stratas
they're in.
>> But that is that's what I got to say.
>> [__] their slum. Oh god, I hate this
mother. Um,
>> yeah, but like don't you want to
convince them, bro? Like, don't you want
to
>> those guys? They're lost. They're lost.
They're lost. They're gone. It's like
trying to convince MAGA. They're gone.
They're gone.
>> What's
Adam doing? Then what's Adam doing?
>> Adam who?
>> Mach.
>> Oh, he's trying to get some of their
audience. I guess he's not going to
convince Hassan. And it's good exposure
for him. It's a [__] market
[clears throat] move, bro.
Oh,
>> he's Griffin.
>> No, that's not one and the same. He
wasn't pretending to be anybody else
than what he wasn't.
>> Well, he's being nice through and
through.
>> If I did that, you know that.
>> It seems. I don't really I don't think
I've again, I don't think I've ever seen
Mockler go in super hard.
He's just a kid.
>> You never seen him going hard. Are you
kidding?
>> Well, you know what I mean, Dan. This is
when I think you're being obtuse.
>> You know exactly what I mean.
>> You're intentionally obtuse.
>> The [__]
>> Honestly, I think a lot more would get
done if if if I did maybe I'll even host
a couple's counseling. I could be the
mediator.
>> Why?
>> Because sometimes you need you need
>> This is so insanely parasocial. This is
like the most parasocial calling I've
seen in my entire life.
>> It's actually crazy.
I'm in no mood to entertain like
overtures of reconciliation of any kind.
Do you understand?
>> I'm not saying reconciliation, but you
were the reason I asked it originally
was because you had said
>> you were asking me all these qu like
about what Destiny thinks. I'm like, I
don't know what the [__] Destiny thinks.
I'm at Destiny.
>> That's why I said, hey, why like if you
have all these questions like you should
just bring him in. I don't know. I don't
have all these questions. Like I I know
what's going on. It's it's it's anger uh
emotion. It doesn't have anything to do
with like
>> you can ask him instead of just assuming
>> he he's not going to cop to that
obviously.
>> Well, let's just see
>> who's waiting to join up on Pisc.
>> Hey, how you doing?
>> Whoa, that was loud.
>> What's going on, man?
>> Not much.
>> So, I've been listening to uh to a bunch
of this. I just have a few questions
just to clarify some things cuz I I
don't fully know what's going on. So
during that debate I did see the clip
Destiny said that Aaron was a Marxist
Linist, right?
>> Correct.
>> Okay. And you said that you said that
she wasn't and you called that a Destiny
lie.
>> Correct.
>> Okay. What What is Aaron then?
>> Aaron is a communist.
>> Okay. I mean earlier in this uh in the
stream you said she was a liberal. Did
you just misspeak?
>> No, I think that she believes in
freedoms. Um, I understand liberalism to
entail protections of liberties. Um, I
guess usually it implies
>> protections from the state
>> and communism kind of entails a
stateless society, but I think that she
would round out some theory of of rights
and freedoms that would be enforced.
>> Is this about Aaron?
>> Indeed.
>> Wait, did they make this about Aaron?
>> Absence of a state. Something like that.
But she does believe in freedoms like
I'm looking at other stuff. I just don't
know that she believes in the state but
the liberties part of liberalism she
believes
>> I mean she has private property though
>> um like I'm not a liberal
>> okay then I will grant that if she takes
liberalism to be a commitment to you
know some sort of statebacked system of
freedoms and rights um then I'm assuming
that's what she's talking about when I
use the term liberal as described to her
what I'm suggesting is that she's
dedicated to democratic processes
which she still believes in and
advocates for and for freedoms. That's
all I mean.
>> Right. So would you be like like an
anarco communist then? Like what what
flavor of communist we talking about
here?
>> I think a flavor of communism which um
sees as its aspiration
>> the abolishment of the state
>> abolishment of private property.
>> Oh man.
>> And the protection of civil liberties
communally. That's how I understand it.
>> Man, that sounds like a bad idea.
Well, whether it's a good or a bad idea
doesn't really relate to whether she's
Marxist London or disagreed.
>> Yeah, it's true. I mean, there's there's
there's the larger conversation of all
>> sharp talk is going to get totally
rolled here. I don't know why he did
this. So, I just Yeah. So, you were just
saying something totally is the coralary
of that. Yeah. Yeah, that's true.
>> Anarchism ends up turning into some
flavor of authoritarianism as soon as
you realize.
>> You would agree that she's not a Marcist
though.
>> So, like
>> you would agree she's not a Marshallist?
Um,
>> I don't think she'd want to be. I think
I think if you gave her like
>> Is she or is she not? Yes, sir. Is is Is
she a Marxist Lenist?
>> I don't think I don't think she'd want
to be. She's sort of like a
consequentially she becomes a Marxist
Leninist because her ideas lead to
Marxist Leninist winning.
>> I'll tell you. I'll tell you. I think I
think if you gave her political power,
she would have to be bounc or is she not
as it is now?
>> As it is right now. No.
>> Okay. I was correct. So, so just be
clear. I was correct when I said she
wasn't Marcus on this. Sure. Yeah. No, I
agree.
>> Okay. And it was wrong it was wrong for
usurp it was wrong for us to suggest
that all communists are Marxist.
Correct.
>> Oh yeah, that's obviously true. Yes. All
communist Marxist.
>> And as though I didn't know wasn't that
she was a communist.
>> So I think it was wrong to say like oh
she's an ML. I think that's that just
wasn't what was in the clip. I still
think what she is is bad but not an ML.
>> Okay. So when you take a clip that
doesn't show Marxist and says she's a
communist and pretend as though I've
been sort of rebutted, that's a lie,
isn't it?
>> No.
>> Virtually was lying there. I think he
was ignorant for a second. He's normal
now. He just misspoke. Yeah. Yeah. I
think so.
>> That's why I personally believe
>> I I don't because if he misspoke, he
should own up to that, right? Say I'm
Wouldn't that be the correct thing to
do?
>> Sure. I mean maybe maybe is listening
here. I don't know. But uh if he is I
would say you know communism and Marxist
Linism are not the same thing. It's very
obvious that straight A's a communist.
It's very obvious her ideas are bad. We
don't even call them evil. But Marxist
Linist I don't think that she is. No.
>> Any other questions for me?
>> Yes. Actually um I I do want a little
bit of clarification on the whole um
Rose was 17 debacle because you said
something along [laughter] the lines of
>> dude I just I really just think you
should be nicer to Destiny. I think
maybe could you just like Destiny again?
I just wish you'd come in and it's just
cringe that you don't like Destiny. By
the way, Pisco treats these people so
special. Okay, if I was doing the kind
of brigading, if anyone was doing the
kind of brigading they do on his
channel, he'd ban them all from his
community. I I feel like I can almost
guarantee that.
It's there's just no way anyone else
would be allowed to.
>> You don't want to venture into the
topic. If you ban this person, it would
be taking a stand on this this story.
You don't want to take a stand on No, I
understand. Um, just hypothetically,
like if Destiny had a chatter that was
named, I don't know, peace go
straighter, would you expect him to ban
that person?
>> Um, I wouldn't expect him to ban that
person currently.
>> Well, why? What? I mean, I think it's
reasonable to expect him to ban that
person. That's that's a crazy name.
>> Well, then the name itself might violate
to
>> I'm not sure. [laughter]
>> Okay.
>> Put aside to I mean moral issues. I mean
morally. I mean morally.
>> Right. right now. You think that he
would ban that person?
>> I would hope so. If it were my
community,
>> it would just be your payment.
>> I would ban someone like I I've had
>> $3 trying to classify an underage
person. BTW I label minor is an anagram
of omniliberal.
>> Hey, thank you very much Ruben Rubin for
reminding us. I would just say does
Destiny currently ban people who dox
people in Australia
>> really really bad disputes with other
creators um in the past and I' I'd
definitely ban them if it were if it
were me.
>> Okay. So you think that I should ban
people who make allegations or whose
names are
>> I mean if if they're allegations. Yeah.
Especially if they're if they're not
founded. Yeah.
>> Okay. So on that view
should I ban Destiny for making a
allegation as to Ethan Klein?
>> Maybe you should. I don't know to be
honest. I'm asking if it were the case.
No. So, it's a conditional. If it were
the made a baseless accusation,
>> then yes, you should.
>> Okay.
>> I um I think
>> that's how I view it.
>> As I sit back and think, I think that um
there are probably some bullets that I'd
bite in terms of moderation of certain
names in my community. But I think that
this particular name is asking me to
venture into an issue which is like
squarely in the heart of things which I
think I have a commitment not to venture
into. You think it's unprincipled for me
to take the stand. Do you think I should
ban this person? Is it their name?
>> Yes. Yes, you should. And in fact, the
fact their name keeps appearing on your
stream on a topic that you you've said
yourself you don't want to talk about. I
mean, they're still appearing there on
your stream. They're in your VOD.
They're in your videos. So that's a good
point. That is in in a way appearing
there. Are they Wait, wait, wait. But
are they commenting on it or is it like
a name that's a reference that you'd
have to know the reference and explain
why they're getting banned?
>> I said I won't talk about it. You think
I should ban all mentions of it in my
community?
>> Maybe. Yeah. If you're going to take
that kind of principal sentence, then
maybe that's the right thing to do.
>> Anything I don't talk about, my
community shouldn't mention.
>> Um, if it's going to be that
inflammatory, I think so. That's pretty
inflammatory.
>> I'm just wondering if I would apply this
to other people. That's a point that I
hadn't considered before which is if I'm
unwilling to discuss something doesn't
make sense to allow other people discuss
in the app but it's there's a range of
issues which I probably like I probably
would be unwilling to discuss certain
allegations like Hassan etc.
I'm not sure I'll think about it because
I haven't I haven't thought about that
particular
yeah sure um any yeah I just these are
just things that I um I didn't quite
know what was going on here so I just
wanted some clarifications on the uh on
the books. Thanks for having me on.
>> No that's good. Hey, thank you so much.
And were you on the debate with Wick as
well with usurp?
>> Uh, I don't know who usurp is. I was on
last night,
>> but it was um it was me, Destiny, and
then two right-wingers debating is Trump
a threat to to free speech. And it was
two like no name guys. No offense to
them. Uh because we couldn't get any
right-wingers to actually pick up the
other side. None of them wanted to
debate it. I even I called in all the
old right-wingers who have hated me now
for years because I apparently
backstabbed them. None of them show up
to the debate.
>> Even though they had to have a big beef
with me, they wouldn't show up. Oh,
welcome.
>> Well, um I've had some trouble in
similar circumstances. We had one um
about the Comey indictments and they
really scraping the bottom of the
barrel.
>> I think I was on that panel with you
actually.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah.
>> But anyway, thank you so much for Yeah.
Good.
>> No, it was it was that one redheaded guy
who was like kind of sick halfway
through it and he like apologized for
how bad he was and it's like, "Listen,
man. You shouldn't have done this
anyway."
>> [laughter]
>> It was uh it was a tough moment for
them, but appreciate
>> like Pisco's reaction to the previous
drama, by the way, where Destiny
wouldn't make a recommendation. Pisco's
reaction to that was, "You don't get to
discuss it in my Discord anymore."
Now, they're all back with the exact
same accusations after Pisco shut it
down in his Discord. They're all back
with the exact same accusations for him.
He took a special action in their favor
trying to prevent this kind of drama and
they're back doing the same kind of
lying about him a few months later.
What does that tell us? I feel like it's
obviously pushing us in the direction of
well these people are just anybody who
doesn't like Destiny they're they're
going to keep blowing up about they're
going to keep getting mad about. Doesn't
matter if the things those people say
are true doesn't none of it matters
right they're going to keep just going
after Pisco for it. They're going to
keep trying to pressure Pisco.
>> Hit you and um
>> goal, especially in the interim,
especially in the short term, is the
defeat of fascism. I believe that the
Republican party
>> No, you don't. No, you don't actually
believe this because you just want
another form of fascism. It's called
Stalinism. It's called now. That's why
you're a cryptofascist. You're the same
exact thing as MAGA. You brought forth
MAGA and so you're exactly the same. You
don't have the same goal. And these
people shouldn't be treated like they
have the same goal. I don't know why
Adam isn't like speaking up right now.
if he maybe Assan has some like dirt on
him or something or maybe he's got like
weird sit I don't even know an illiberal
party a post-lberal party whatever you
want to call it and I think unlike uh
the uh historic inception of fascism as
a revolutionary movement at a time when
liberalism was failing only a hundred
years ago this time we have two liberal
parties in America like as as a
political theory we have two liberal
parties right like we say conservative
whatever but like technic
>> no it's better now. It was not good at
the start and people weren't giving me
the actual time stamp. Now it's getting
better.
>> Republicans are also a liberal uh party.
Um
>> and am I laring right now? Wait, are you
serious? Wait, wait, Kinda, just to be
clear, Kinda,
you think that you agree with Adam that
we're all united in one goal, that he's
not here to shame anybody for voting one
way or voting another, that it's
ridiculous to get commitments from
Newsome if he's the nominee, that we're
going to agree a lot on terms of
criticism of the Democratic party and
where the party needs to go. Am I laring
right now? Wait, are you serious? Wait,
wait, Kinda, just to be clear, Kinda,
you think that you agree with Adam that
we're all united in one goal, that he's
not here to shame anybody for voting one
way or voting another, that it's
ridiculous to get commitments from
Newsome if he's the nominee, that we're
going to agree a lot on terms of
criticism of the Democratic party and
where the party needs to go, and that he
should be conceding that he's
disillusioned with the Democratic party.
I'm going to say Pisco's too to know
that Kinda is disabled. Okay? He's too
realize that he doesn't know. That's not
his fault
>> in front of us. I just want to make
sure. Kinda, do you agree with all of
what Adam said there, Kinda?
>> This is just for Kinda. Those are all
things that Adam said and you're gonna
pretend that you're okay with that.
>> Not cool, man. Not cool. Not cool. Very
not cool.
>> Cuz we'll have Kinda on right now just
to discuss those points. It's been a
minute in this discussion and we've
already had five concessions.
>> Okay. I seen, by the way, I've seen like
five DGers and zero people. I Oh, no.
Sugar is someone I recognize. Although I
don't think they're super political, but
I've seen like five DJers and no none of
these like crazy leftists yet. We'll
see. I'm sure they'll show up. Oh, hold
on. There's there's one. [laughter]
>> Not entirely, but I wouldn't go as hard
as you are. [laughter]
>> NO, PISCO. NO, SHE'S she's totally
taking it seriously. Oh, no. Oh, no.
>> What the Oh, dude. Why would you ever as
a liberal streamer go in front of a
tanky anti-semite like Hassan [__] want
a a productive conversation as though
it's possible with a bad faith hack?
Quote, "We're all united in one goal."
You need to understand that he's a
tanky. He's anti-liberal. They use
liberal as a slur. Then Adam says he's
not here to shame anyone for voting one
way or not voting the other. And you're
like, "Uh, it's not that bad. It's not
that bad."
>> What?
>> Dude.
Dude, [sighs and gasps]
uh,
>> you have no response, right? Clinda, you
have no response. You think that that's
okay. That before any debate, you
concede.
>> She She's starting to get it and she has
to say this is great. I don't I don't
believe she'll believe it's great, but
okay.
>> We should have a productive conversation
with a bad faith hack,
>> that we're all united in one goal. Here,
I'm quoting. I'm quoting, right? This is
in fact, we can go right back to the
beginning.
>> We haven't even started a discussion.
And he's already conceded. You guys, I
know you want me to pull up DGG logs. I
can pull up screenshots of specific logs
sometimes, but you have to understand
I'll never be able to just pull up DGG
wholesale because it's the same as
pulling up a bad empanada video without
looking up looking up anything in it,
right? Or or watching it. Like you
cannot you cannot platform like do like
places you know docs are or where
they're at a high risk of platforming
somebody's docs. You can't search
through those without knowing what's
there. Like you you can't do that.
Unironically, I'm saying this totally
seriously. You cannot do that. Marma,
dude, thank you very much for the 500.
>> Pisco needs to fully take the gloves
off. Stop placating Destiny, who's now
doing the same creulying he accused
others of.
>> Yeah, I think Pisco is doing that. I
don't have to do anything. I'm just I'm
uh how do I put it?
Oh, also
yes, I think he's doing that already.
I'm just uh I Nothing. There's nothing.
I just think he's doing it already.
There's actually nothing else to add.
So, thank you very much for the 500
kicks. Marma dude, I also forgot to
thank Trucker Nate earlier for the 500
kicks. Thank you so much, Trucker Nate.
I really appreciate it.
>> He wants to have a productive
conversation. We're all united in one
goal. He's not here to shame anybody for
voting one way or not voting another one
way, for voting one way or not voting
one way. He thinks it's ridiculous to
get commitments to vote for Newsome. And
we're going to agree a lot in terms of
criticism of the Democratic party and
where the party needs to go. Oh, wait.
No. I'm just asking you specifically.
Isn't that up that he would do this,
Kinda? that he would concede at the
start like this.
>> Oh no, Kinda is definitely going to be
on. Isn't there some talking point about
how Adam was being consiliatory to get
Hassan to say like really really
incorrect or incoherent things and that
by Adam was playing like 40 chess and
was finding a way to make Hassan say
like totally inconsistent things, but
like that's why he let Hassan talk the
whole time. I think there's some talking
points like that out there that there's
some [__] going on.
>> What? This isn't debate mode. What are
you talking about? Wait. User, can you
uh I just want you to join. You can call
me, right? Can you you want to call
right now?
I just want to get uh
>> debate mode. Oh, did this surf guy?
>> We We might have to watch Dude, do we
just do me? Am I going to have to start
with the other might have to start with
that other content tomorrow or
something? God damn it.
Oh,
>> this is my first time watching.
>> This is rough, man. This is rough. Do
you think Destiny Hutch's gaslighting
worked on Pisco? I don't think Hutch was
gaslighting. I think he genuinely I I
said like I do think Hutch is probably
somewhat like annoyed. You read mean
comments about yourself, you're always
annoyed. Even if you've done something
to like bring those mean comments on,
even if they're like accurate but mean
comments. You're always annoyed with
somebody who like would allow that to
happen. It's about whether or not it's
fair to expect them to do something. I
always knew Hutch was annoyed. I said as
much when we when he first came in. I
just thought, "Oh, well, he's not going
to let his friend get over. he's not
going to work with like this um like I
thought he basically the way I saw it
was he's capable of seeing like a bigger
picture and that he's not going to sue
Pisco right now cuz Pisco could you know
Hutch could have done a lot of damage to
Pisco I don't think he did as with what
he said but I do think I do think Pisco
was like totally crushing Destiny until
Hutch came in and was like no I've
actually mentioned your chat to you a
lot
um unlucky because you get you just get
to paint Pisco as like totally um as
like lying. They'll just say Pisco is
lying about not knowing that Hutch
wanted some moderation or something,
right? That's where it'll go. So, it's
too bad cuz Pisco totally dominated the
conversation, but it won't matter now.
Unlucky, man. Unlucky. Not that like I
guess I should be realistic. It would
never have mattered to those people ever
in the first place,
right? It would never have mattered to
those people like like they already hate
Pisco. So it it just actually the the
concrete reality is this doesn't matter,
man. But it would have looked good for,
you know, hypothetically like three
people. Ban all tankies from this chat
right now. I would have no viewers if we
banned all the tankies. Oh, no.
>> I'm quoting. Okay. Well, all right.
We'll go right back to the start and
we'll see if I misrepresented anything
of what I just said. that Kinda and
usurper are now sweeping for Adam who's
sweeping for Hassan. Just keep that in
mind.
>> Let me fix that.
>> Yeah. And I'll also up your volume as
well.
>> It's getting funnier. It's getting
funnier.
>> Yes. A few things. [snorts] Um let me
make sure you can hear me correctly.
>> Yeah, I can hear you. I crank.
>> I want this to be a productive
conversation.
>> That was the first thing I said. He
wants it to be a productive
conversation. That was accurate.
But Hassan is a bad faith piece of he is
incapable of having productive
conversations.
>> He's like a Marxist Leninist who yeah he
lies about everything except when he
like says something bad. If he says the
word re-education then he's like then
he's like mask off. Okay. But when he
says things like I I like democracy. I
want to I want to achieve like some
socialist goals through democracy.
That's mask on. He's just hiding. He's
lying. Okay. He only wants to embed
himself within the Democratic party when
he had the conversation with Oh, what
are these stinky [__] cult
>> the D program? Oh no, now I'm now I'm
actually starting my ears are actually
burning. Maybe Pisco. Maybe he actually
is watching a little bit.
>> It's called the D something. Ooh, the D
something. What is it called?
>> Oh no,
>> the distributor.
>> I didn't mean to do this. I'm sorry. I'm
sorry.
>> Drogram. The drogram podcast. Do you
see? Did you see the aerodyite debate?
Yeah. I find me clips. I will never ever
watch whatever ever again. If whatever
starts bounding in the thing to like 2
hours or something, maybe 8 8 hour 47
minutes off. What trash content. He said
he was going to embed himself by hiding
his views.
And Adam wants to have a productive
conversation with you. You need to know
you're not going to have productive
conversation with someone whose only job
is to defeat the Democratic party. So
that's number one. I wasn't wrong about
that. He did say he wanted a productive
conversation. That shows he's naive.
>> I want to make sure we can make
>> Yeah, just call me on VC and I'll call
you.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay.
>> Am I good to call conversation and
acknowledging and conceding that we're
all we quotes and representations are
accurate.
>> Also, I have to get like water and a pop
and I'm going to grab some of that food.
I got sushi like rolls as well. So, I'm
gonna hope those are like defrosted.
I sat outside for a while, but hopefully
I'm actually going to try to eat
something because I've not eaten
anything yet. I'll be right back.
>> For anyone who doesn't know, that's my I
froze my sushi order when I first
started the stream. It's [__] up.
>> So, one productive
>> sitting on my
>> I left it sitting on my doorstep for
like two hours at the start of my
stream. It was messed up. Okay,
>> I think we're all united in one goal of
beating.
>> He says we're all united, including
Hassan. we we are all united in one
goal.
His first statements are saying he wants
to have a productive conversation and
acknowledging and conceding that we're
all on the same page. That is Adam
sanewashing Hassan. Do you understand
how that's saneashing Hassan? He's
conceding that we all share the same
goal. I'm going to call you. Wait, this
is actually really harmful. I'm calling
you a ser.
>> Wait, wait, wait. I was away. I was
away. I was away. What did Pisco just
say? Did he just say what I think he
just said? There's no way.
>> I'm going to call you. Wait.
>> Did I go far enough?
>> This is actually really harmful. I'm
calling you, assur.
>> Oh, I didn't go back far enough. Hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
>> Did say he wanted a productive
conversation. Why he would start this
way?
>> Hold on. Hold on. Come on. Hold on.
>> Hang on. Just make sure my rest the rest
of my quotes and representations are
accurate. So, one productive
>> some progress because I think we're all
united in one goal of beating.
>> He says we're all united, including
Hassan. We we're all united in one goal.
His first statements are saying he wants
to have a productive conversation and
acknowledging and conceding that we're
all on the same page. That is Adam
sanewashing Hassan. Do you understand
how that's saying washing Hassan?
>> What
what he's cons what
what did he just did he just
what
why would he say that? Why would he say
that? Why would he Why would he say
that? Why would he say those words? Why
would he say that?
>> Seeding that we all share the same goal.
>> I didn't even grab my sushi. I just came
back to do that bit. One second.
>> I'm going to call you. Wait. This is
actually really harmful. I'm calling
you. Yo, what up? Wait, can you hear me?
Oh, one second. I can't hear you.
Can't hear you. One sec.
How about now?
>> Uh, can you hear me? I can hear you loud
and clear. Can you hear me?
>> Yeah. How you doing, bro?
>> I'm doing well, man. How you doing? Not
so well, man. My first time listening to
this [__]
>> Listen, I don't I didn't I didn't come
in saying that you made any
misrepresentation. Just seem they turned
on the stream. You just seem hot. And
>> yeah, no, I I'm kind of hot because like
Adam,
>> he's like 10 or 20 seconds into this
debate and he's said that he wants to
have a productive conversation with a
bad face. He's a hack and that we're all
united in one goal. I think he's like
conceding the framing. He's conceding
the framing that we're all on the same
team. We're part of the same coalition
and he's sane Hassan. Would you agree
with that?
I mean, I guess so in the way if you
just wanted to do that, but can I give
you a counter about
>> Yeah. Now I'm starting to see why um
now I'm seeing why Pisco had to die
today. Why they had to go and try to sue
this guy again, right? Like literally
the idea the idea that you could have a
productive conversation with leftists
right now. Um yeah, Pisco's got to go
down today. I I see I see I see what
happened. I see it. I see it. Wait,
wait, wait. When you say in a way, what
do you mean in a way?
>> Because I would only imagine because you
said it was the first 20 seconds and I
can imagine somebody coming in. I don't
know if these guys have ever talked
before and I can just see you not
wanting to come in swinging fist right
away. You might want to come in, you
know, just being cordial, being polite,
trying to see maybe you can have a
normal conversation, but if I can
understand if you don't like if you
think that he doesn't deserve any of
that credit at all, then I'm just I can
see how you might think that.
>> I think you've he's already given up at
the start because like we need to excise
these people from our coalition. Like
Hassan is waiting
>> because I can This is what I was asking
when I Well, this is what I meant when
you came in hot. You just It just seems
that I don't know the conversation you
had with um with Hutch the other day
like it just you just seem different
today.
>> I don't know how you mean in the
conversation with Hutch, I never made it
like even close to the impression that I
thought Hassan's on the same team. I
said he was mostly bad faith. I said he
was illiberal. And so so I I would was
very clear I was very clear in our
conversation was talking nice to him. I
wasn't saying you were like glazing him
but you weren't like this. And I think
if you don't know what I mean when I do
this and you're just
>> because I view Hutch as an ally part of
the coalition and I think he just has a
wrong impression of me that I would
support someone like Assan. So that
doesn't really get me animated cuz I'm
just trying to basically have good
communication with him. The reason I was
hot is because Adam is literally saying
watching a tanky
>> and and so like I'm nice with Hutch
because he's part of the coalition and
I'm trying to convince him that I am
part of the coalition and I'm more hot
when I hear a liberal try to wash us on
and conceal. Okay, hold on. Pisco is
really good at smiling during the bit.
Oh, no he's not. Sorry, not smiling. Not
ever smiling during the bit. He's not
actually Pisco had to learn how to
smile. Okay. He's he's like he he didn't
know how to smile growing up and he's
never been taught. Didn't have that
emotion. Okay. He just didn't that him
feeling happy is not connected to him
smiling. So actually the thing you're
perceiving is that the illusion that he
smiles a lot otherwise is just a learned
behavior. Okay. That's all it is.
>> See that we're all going towards the
same goal when we're very clearly not.
>> Can I
>> He's just he's actually just relaxing
when he doesn't smile ever during the
bit.
>> Chillax.
>> Can I ask if you if like you're are you
changing your method in which you're
doing it now? Like are you saying that
now you're acting a little hotter?
>> No, I've always been hot against Hanky
like Assant.
>> I've always said that they're not part
of the team. Yeah, I've always said
that.
>> Yeah, I think you always said I think
you've always said that they've like
haven't necessarily been part of the
team. But I also think that like while
you haven't been like glazing them or
supporting them or even agreeing with a
lot of their ideas, you've kind of given
them a little bit of a benefit of the
doubt like is not even like in a bad
way, but you're a nicer guy when you
have these conversations like
necessarily like when you go up against
a person like Rob Nure. Yeah. you're
going to go at his throat because he's a
mega- conservative and they're
disgusting creatures and they're so
obviously not on our side. But I think
that you had almost a thought of, you
know what, these guys are might be
farther left than us. They might
actually be communist and they might
actually want some crazy stuff, but you
know what, the enemy of the enemy is my
friend and my real enemy over there,
MAGA, is so bad that I'll even attempt
to be cordial with people on the left,
further left than me. And I think that's
what you were doing before. So,
[clears throat]
>> so you surf guy is suspicious but not
sure. Well, you missed the very
embarrassing part of this debate a
little earlier, Semaphore, where this
usurp guy was talking to Pisco and
literally was like begging to moderate a
conversation between Pisco and Destiny.
>> Okay. Very, very embarrassing. I guess
like
>> even if I were to concede that even if I
were to concede that,
>> which I don't concede, even if I were,
that's what Adam's doing here in a much
more sympathetic and sane washi way that
I even could be ever accused of. I would
never do this concession that we're all
towards the same goal of Hassan
I didn't come,
>> but I got criticized by people for how I
went. And so this is even worse even if
you believe them than that. And so I
know this can't be
>> again. I [clears throat] think it's
different when it's the first 20 seconds
of the conversation, especially if you
don't know how the rest goes cuz maybe
after the 5minute mark, it's a blood
bath. Not that you don't know that yet.
>> Well, I just want to know like if he
were ever to say something like I don't
know um that he doesn't even consider it
bad
endorse Kamala, he doesn't hold it
against him. If you were to ever say
something like that, I mean that would
be saying
>> No, it wouldn't just be that. I mean,
no, [laughter] this isn't this isn't a
real debate. You that they're not really
having conversation right now.
>> I don't think Adam I don't even know if
Adam came in as a debate because even
like he was calm the entire time cuz
I've watched I didn't watch all of it or
like I was just I was doing other stuff
when I was listening to it. But even
like Hassan at one point um said like,
"Hey, you like brought up like, "Oh,
you're bringing up like a debate bro
strategy when I think for the most time
Adam was just trying to have a quiet."
Wait, since you got the Hassan line
open, you got to get the Pisco tiny
combo reacted to on stream. Um,
no, I don't think so.
And one, I wouldn't abuse my connection
my deep my deep connection to Hassan.
Okay, I wouldn't use it like that. That
would be weird. Okay.
But I don't think I don't think this is
the kind of thing Hassan would react to.
You'd have to get somebody on the page
of understanding that Destiny's trying
to do some of the same things he did to
Hassan or anyone else who's broken out
of his community. You'd have to get him
to understand that. I don't know if
Hassan's picking that up yet. We'll see.
>> I conversation. I think maybe his
strategy.
>> No, no, no. No, no, no. No, no, no. You
can't have a quiet conversation with
these people. You need to go in there
and make make them know that they're not
welcome in our coalition. this like it
would be like trying to go into the MAGA
space and just glaze them and be like
it's okay that you voted for Trump. It's
not okay.
>> Well, it could you have a conversation
with somebody that you disagree with in
a way that you're acting calm and by and
by you acting calm and just asking kind
of the same questions over and over
again, it ends up making the other
person look bad anyway, even though you
weren't confrontational and hostile
during [clears throat] the conversation.
>> I'm not so sure about that. I'm not so
sure about that.
>> Wait, wait.
>> I Yeah. No, I don't really think that
that can happen.
>> Explain that. Well, you remember I made
this mistake with the Vanguard, you
know, a week or two ago where
>> I was nice or whatever and I just
>> That can't possibly be true or else you
wouldn't have been able to accuse Pisco
of like sweeping for tankies obviously,
right?
>> Just kept asking if they would support
the Democratic party and I realized that
that was saying Washington some tanky
who are the enemy. All these people are
the enemy and so I've been convinced by
people like um you know just like random
people whoever that that that's not
good. So no just like random people.
>> Yeah, you weren't you weren't here for
this earlier. Ethan Klein and Totally
Not Kosher Kathy. You you definitely you
weren't here earlier, but um I know that
you get mad at me for defending Loader
Box all the time. And then they're like,
"Oh, I think I think JTO he uses Jtock
talking points." It's like one
I've explicitly like pushed back on that
idea multiple times, including when
Hassan said it. I said that's like, you
know, you're you know you're making that
up, right?
And two, I called to sought out even
when he tweeted something that was
hinting at that before. Right.
And three, I've talked to Loterbox in
private about how I don't appreciate
that kind of convers that kind of talk.
And he's like I I literally have talked
to Loterbox about this before, like
specifically the chatters. And I correct
the Lonerbox's dad was a Garinite every
single time it's brought up. Like
anytime I see that in chat, I say that's
insane. Don't don't say that. Obviously.
So, I don't know. It's like there's just
evidence like Loader Box has literally
talked to me about this stuff.
Well, he was a Marinite. Oh, whatever.
That he was at Saburn Chhatilla and
killed a bunch of Palestinians. Whatever
the I don't know if he was flangist. Why
did I say why did I say Marinite? I
meant fangist. They say that his dad was
a flangist at Saburn Chhatilla. I said
Maronite instead of fangis earlier
tonight now and I look
sorry I don't if you don't like talked
about this stuff very often it goes out
of your head. No it's not nitpicky they
were they were the philangists. That was
the name of the militia. It's not
nitpicky. It's just true. I feel for
saying it like that earlier today.
Whatever you continue I'm almost done
with this.
>> Okay. I mean listen I think I listen I
think everybody knows you're trolling
and I understand why you're doing this.
You're having like an extreme reaction
to the conversations that you've been
having.
>> An extreme reaction. This is an it's an
extreme reaction. What is this?
>> Extreme reaction compared to your normal
stream personality. Yeah.
>> I don't know what you're talking about.
>> Wait. Come on, dude.
>> I legit know what you're talking about.
So, he's
How dare Pisco meme? How dare Pisco have
fun? Are you having fun on your stream?
That's a bit of an extreme reaction,
don't you think? H like I know that the
guy who I post clips for, the guy who
I'm most aligned with politically, the
guy who I show for all the time, I know
he just called for you to get kicked off
of your own podcast, but like don't you
think you're having a bit of a an
extreme reaction to that? Don't you
think this is like a bit extreme, man?
Don't you think you're like being a bit
extreme?
>> He starts off the debate. This Sorry,
it's not a real debate. This is even a
conver like go through this debate.
>> Yeah, sure. Let's do it. Yeah. Yeah.
It's It's not a real conversation,
though. I just want you to know that.
Can you admit it's not a real
conversation?
>> Well, you haven't watched it. How would
you know? Well, so far I can already
tell this is not a real debate. This is
this is a debate.
>> Oh, did somebody watch it? Someone is a
real debate. How will I do this? Can you
share your screen in 100%? Yeah, I can
do that. All right. You
>> I want this to be a productive
conversation. I want to make sure we can
make some progress because I think we're
all united in one goal of beating
fascism at the end of the day. And I'm
>> Can I just Can I just agree that he
should have said that at the start,
right? Yes or no?
>> He shouldn't have said we're all in it
together to defeat fascism.
>> Yeah, he shouldn't have said that.
Correct. Cuz it's wrong. It's it's a
lie. So, he shouldn't say You agree it's
wrong, right? Because we're not we don't
have the same goal. So, it's untrue.
Correct. Well, I guess is it untrue? Yes
or not right now? No. No. I'm asking if
if the same is true.
>> Yes.
>> The statement is true. Wait, so Hassan
and Hassan's Hassan's end political goal
wouldn't necessarily be fascism. So
yeah, right now their goal would be to
unite to defeat fascism in Hassan's
ideal world after that fact. Then he
would then defeat the liberals to get
communism and Mauism or Stalinism,
whatever you want, whatever of the month
is.
>> So you wouldn't have a problem with me
saying that Hassan and I share the same
goal of ending fascism. If I were to say
that, you would have a problem with
that?
>> No, I guess it would. But I think the
conversation goes a little bit deeper
than that.
>> Well, I just mean that statement in
isolation. Correct.
>> Yeah. Exact. Yeah. In isolation. But
you're but actions aren't in isolation.
>> Yes. Of course. I I totally agree.
>> For voting one way or not voting one
way.
>> Uh I don't like that concession either.
So he said he's not here to shame people
for voting one way or the other.
Shouldn't he be shaming people? Why
isn't that like bad?
>> I disagree with him on that one. Yeah.
>> Okay. So that that's horrible.
>> I honestly don't even think you guys all
have to line up behind Gavin Newsome two
years before the [__] primary.
>> That's up. He's saying he's preending.
>> 100% normal. Yeah. No, it's normal.
>> Wait, it's normal.
>> No one was saying that. Yeah. No one was
saying that Hassan needed to get behind
Gavin Newsome now. that he was asked in
a hypothetical election when it was JD
Vance and Gavin Newsome.
>> Oh, you think this comment is just for
the primary?
>> Wait, what?
>> This do you think the comment about we
don't need to line up to support Gavin
Newsome? You think that he said that
just with respect to the primary, not
the general?
>> I think he said that as in like, hey, we
haven't gone through the primary
process, right, yet? So, we don't need
everybody to get behind this one
individual.
>> Oo, that is ultra good faith. That is Do
you understand how this is? Cuz it's
ultra good faith. You're trying to find
any way to even conceivably slightly be
good faith about how he's interpreted
the state in the most charitable most
[__] charitable way possible. But
when you know other people say [__] yo
calm down calm down when this guy when
why did he bring up this question? Why
did he make make that statement at him
there?
>> He's clearly referencing. You got to be
a [__] idiot. He's clearly
referencing the
>> [__] whole controversy. Obviously
>> the Jennifer Welsh one. Yeah. What was
the question that Jennifer Welsh asked?
>> Yeah. If they want
>> I'll be I'll be real.
I do think Pisco's been watching the
stream. Okay. I think Pisco is like my
biggest fan. Pretty sure he's been
watching the stream a lot. Doing a lot
of references, a lot of callbacks to the
stream. All right. I It's hard not to
think so. Okay.
>> On the primary, obviously. Yeah. So, why
would he say you don't have to get
behind him now? Yeah. Because he's
trying to give him cover.
>> It's so up. Okay. It's so up that Pisco,
Destiny, and Hassan are all watching and
they won't direct. Only Only Destiny
will direct people to my stream. Okay,
sorry. I I didn't want to I didn't give
him props there. And I should give them
props. Okay, out of these three, they're
all watching at the same time. And
Destiny's the only one who will direct
people to my stream.
It's so up, man. It's so up.
God, it's so messed up, man.
>> And sweep for his answer there.
>> You'd think I get a shout out. He might
ask some questions later on. He's
already given away the store. thinks
that, hey, you're allowed to to um
promote and support anybody through the
Democratic primary,
>> right? But the context say, but the
context here is Hassan is already he's
already said that he won't after the
general. And so by saying this, it makes
it appear to a neutral audience that
he's okay with Hassan's um broader
outlook on Gavin Newsome and he's okay
with all the slander and that on a daily
basis um Hassan [__] will spread about
Gavin Newsome. The framing so the
framing no no the framing is obviously
here is sane washing overall outlook on
Gavin Newsome. By the way, if you're
like a leftist tanky, I don't have
enough representation of those in my
Discord. So, discord.gg/jstlk,
hop in, okay? Only leftist tankies.
We've got enough liberals. We've got
enough overt fascists. Way too many, in
fact. But if you're a leftist tanky,
okay, we need you in the Discord. We
need participation from you guys in the
Discord. Okay. So, discord.gg/jdk.
Hop in, please. Thank you.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. On this one, but
>> wait, wait. So, so you wouldn't have a
problem with me like going and saying,
you know, I I don't I'm not asking you
to sign up to support Gavin Newsome.
That's an okay thing to say.
>> Yeah.
>> So, so far
>> support anybody. However, at the end of
the day, when it's on election day on
November 4th, whatever it is this year,
you're goddamn right. If it is Gavin
Newsome, you stand behind him.
>> Okay. Well, hopefully he'll get that
concession in this video.
>> Well, I mean, that's what he's probably
going to try to do. I hope because that
was the big thing with the Jennifer W. I
would I would hope I would hope he would
ask the hypothetical again, right? If he
doesn't, that would be like Horrible.
>> I mean, he's what? You He's a kid.
>> Wait, are we doing this whole Michael?
Michael Michael. Uh,
>> no. I'm just You're almost acting as a
What? No. Hold on. Piss off.
>> He's a kid.
>> Stop. Stop. He's just a kid, man. You
know what? But are you Are you seriously
trying to say that every conversation
needs to be perfect?
>> Do you really think? Cuz I feel like
[laughter]
>> I want you to steal my I want you to try
to steal my position. Just steal my
position. You really think I said that?
>> Yeah, I did. No, I'm not obviously
saying that. I'm obviously saying that
the main as man that's why I said you're
being so hot.
>> No, I'm not hot at all. I'm just I'm
just mad because he's trying to embed
himself in the party and Adam who's on
mightest touch one of the biggest
liberal streamers is basically giving at
least some optical cover for Hassan
[__] and approaching this in a friendly
manner and in that sense at least the
framing you'd agree is sane Washington.
The very fact that he's here and it's
not
>> hostile mean so far.
>> We're about 10 seconds in.
>> Okay, I think that proves my point more
than anything. But
>> why? Wait, why does that prove your
point? Because you're because you this
is obviously all for show. Like we all
know that this isn't what you're
actually upset about. You're upset about
other things and you're just kind of
like
>> So So you think I shouldn't be upset?
Wait, I shouldn't be upset when like
someone saying watches a danky.
>> Well, no, you should be. But I also we
also all realize that it was
conversations you've had earlier this
week that are leading you to act like
this in the show.
>> Okay. No, no, no. Okay. Okay. Gay. This
guy does this guy is identifying that
Pisco is doing a good or bad. It's not
right or wrong. Are you telling me that
I shouldn't like update how I approach
these conversations in response to
suggestions about how light I'm going on
hankies?
>> You could, but there's also something
called like overcorrection.
>> You think I've overcorrected so far by
calling out and saying we have the same
goal?
>> Yeah, I would say right now you are
overcorrecting. Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Wow.
The argument is this uh that Pisco like
believes you should be able to talk to
lefties and this guy is going to always
be upset about Hassan and so Pisco is
doing an overt like satire on people who
want you never to talk to lefties,
right? And this guy's upset that Pisco
is making fun of lefties the whole time.
Okay. Also, I think this guy was was
basically trying to say that Pisco's
chat is like a lefty chat that they're
like insane and he was on that whole
thing. All right. And Adam right now is
doing excellent, right?
We've I've watched like 15 seconds,
dude. How the hell am I going to judge
his performance primary? We have an
exciting ideological battle coming up.
So, I'm not asking you to like jump up
and down for Gavin Newsome. However, I
do want to talk about your response to
Jennifer Welch on that podcast.
>> I know I I don't think I don't think
this guy is biting down on this. I think
he can understand that Pisco is doing
the opposite of his opinion right now.
>> I think we this is good. [clears throat]
He's like he's
>> have some thoughts and I think version
of what a lot of people on Twitter are
trying to say but kind of getting
muddled in. But, um yeah, we're going to
agree on a lot regarding criticism.
>> No, it's not getting muddled. Like, I
hate this. He's already pre-apologizing
for liberal commentators who are in
Assange's replies.
>> I think it is getting muddled a little
bit like I for I can just think of one
muddle from this conversation which was
the hey would you um would you support
him in the or would you support Gavin
Newsome against JD Vance in the election
and he said no and now other people
defending Hassan are saying hey everyone
wants us to line up behind Gavin Newsome
right now and it's two years away. I
think that's part of the muddling of
this conversation. I think that's a part
of all the conversations we've been
having politically for on the left and
the right. We just can't have honest
conversations with anybody about
anything. And that's part of the
problem. Anyway,
>> I don't think that it's good framing for
us to apologize for liberal commentators
who are all pretty much we all know that
they're pretty much discussed about the
same thing. We all know that. And for
Adam to hear it like apologize be like
it's getting muddled. No, the people who
are doing the muddle apology or just an
or describing what's happen it's
assuming responsibility when the
muddling is being done by these tanky
loser who can't answer a question and
keep trying to change.
>> How do they apologize? just by by
acknowledging it
>> because acknowledging that it's
happening.
>> He's pretending as though the fault is.
>> Okay, never mind. The guy doesn't
realize it's a bit
>> the messaging liberals.
>> Wait, can you
>> Oh, yes, absolutely. I absolutely can.
Yes, 100%.
>> Look at how he says this.
>> Coming up. So, I'm not asking you to
like jump up and down for Gavin Newsome.
However, I do want to talk about your
response to
>> Dude, how
bro How are these your guys? These are
like your best guys. This is like your
best guy right now,
bro. If I'm pretty sure if if Substance
got a straight got on a stream, if
Simply Substance got on a stream right
now and looked this,
I I don't think I could recover from
that. Okay, I just couldn't I couldn't
actually recover from that. That would
be rough.
>> That would be really rough, man.
>> I do have some thoughts and I think I
can bring a pretty good faith version of
what a lot of people on Twitter are
trying to say, but kind of
>> they're trying to say it, right? Right.
As in they're failing. They're they're
trying to say it, but they're not doing
a good job of it.
>> Okay. Yeah. And then look in
>> and then it's getting muddled. No. No.
Absolutely. No. He's saying liberals are
like trying to explain something to you
as though they're doing a bad job of it.
That's obviously what he's saying.
Obviously.
>> No. You're off.
>> You don't agree with that.
>> Your radar is off.
>> What do you think he's What do you think
he's saying there? That it's just like
an honest mistake.
>> Trying to accurately describe the
situation that's happening on Twitter
over the past week.
>> You don't think it's by and large tanky
trying to deflect and change the
subject? You you think it's liberals
were not being accurate and calibrated?
No, I think everyone is probably being a
little bit wacky, but I do think the
Yankees are worse, obviously. But
>> Okay, so why not mention that? So why
not mention that?
>> Because again, he's in the very
beginning of the conversation. He said
he's trying to come into it in good
faith.
Good faith. One part about being good
faith is actually coming in willing to
have a conversation.
>> Wait, why would you ever be good faith
to Hassan when he has showed
consistently he'll just lie. He'll lie
about his positions. There's no point
being good faith about his arguments.
>> Because some people are just built to
yell at Hassan all day every day and
treat him like a dog. other people are
better suited to go in and have
conversations like this where maybe Adam
is able to get a couple people who are
watching Hassan. They'll watch this
whole conversation. See how you know
Weaszly
>> Adam built diff little bro Adam built
diff if you were like Adam or Destiny
Pisco you could have conversations with
leftists but actually you're too naive
and nice Pisco you know the things Pisco
is known for being like way too nice to
people way too forgiving of people you
know that that kind of thing. Yeah Pisco
Pisco is just too nice to talk to these
leftists. I I'm pretty sure that Hassan
was in this during this debate. You
>> think Assan Hassan getting a from Adam
Mockler and Adam being super nice is
going to win him over respect and fans.
No, they think you're weak. Obviously,
>> again, the comment like you said, you
said you haven't watched this, so how
are you saying that?
>> Well, I suspected just based on the
introduction here.
>> And okay,
>> regarding criticism of the Democratic
party, probably where the Democratic
Party needs to go will agree a lot.
>> He says he agrees with a lot of Hassan's
criticism of Democrats. He has the most
unhinged criticism of Democrats and he
agrees with Han on where Democrats need
to go. You okay with that?
>> Are you okay with that?
>> Dumb comment. Yeah, that was a dumb
comment.
>> No, that that's like up, right?
>> Calm down, dude. This is
>> Wait, wait. What do you mean calm down?
>> You're doing a good job. Listen, I know
you're having fun like doing this, but
>> we just If you admit it, it would be
much better.
>> Wait, wait, wait. Hang on, hang on a
second. No, I just want to make sure
that we understand what he just said. He
just said, "I agree with a lot of your
criticism." Yeah. Yeah. Make sure. Just
make sure. ever. I do want to talk about
your response to Jennifer Welch on that
podcast because I do have some thoughts
and I think I can bring a pretty good
faith version of what a lot of people on
Twitter are trying to say but kind of
getting muddled in. But um yeah, we're
going to agree on a lot regarding
criticism of the Democratic party where
the Democratic party needs to go. We'll
agree on the Democratic party.
>> No, but he's saying he'll agree with
>> Hassan's criticism of the Democrats.
That's unhinged.
>> He's sweeping so hard.
>> Wait, Hassan? No, it's bad faith. Hassan
doesn't want the Democratic party to do
well. He's a sabotur. He works for MAGA.
Why would you agree with Hassan's
criticism of the Democratic party and
where it needs to go? Wait, do you not
agree with that? Why are you laughing?
>> No, I I think that he can have
disagreements and those disagreements
can actually line up with reality. Let's
say that he says that Joe Biden should
have stepped out earlier.
>> What?
>> I would agree with that.
>> Do you understand you understand why
they wanted Joe Biden to step out,
right?
>> Yeah. So they can
>> It's cuz they called him genocide Joe.
It's cuz they called him genocide Joe,
>> obviously.
>> Right.
>> And why else would he want that? What
else was wrong with him?
>> Well, no. That that's they would No,
they don't care about winning. They just
want their own candidates in installed
and they don't give a they don't give a
[__] about
>> what else is wrong with Biden in the
leadup to the election.
>> Well, obviously [clears throat] they'll
agree he's old, but that's just the way
to get him to drop out because of Gaza.
If you were old and like trying to focus
in on the other thing, so like why would
you agree?
>> Dude, it's actually way better than I
expected. Okay. Okay. I'm seeing it. I'm
seeing it. Oh my goodness. It's actually
even better than I expected cuz he's
like basically this guy's to go No, no,
no, no. And the funny thing is is he's
not really even doing like a caricature.
Like he's basically just quoting while
sounding serious. He's more or less just
quoting. Okay.
>> Biden stepping out. Now the reason they
want to step out could be two different
things. But they both agree that he
should have stepped down earlier. And
that maybe either either would in Adam's
mind give Kamla a better chance of
winning or in Hassan's mind maybe I
don't know Bernie Sanders or AOC have a
better chance.
>> This is so ultra charitable. You would
never give this good faith to someone
like Hutch. to someone like Hutch. You
would never be this good faith to
someone like Hutch.
>> This guy's going back and forth between
realizing it's a bit and then he like
thinks Pisco is not doing the bit
anymore and then he gets confused when
Pisco is still doing the bit. He like
somehow thinks Pisco is like falling out
of the bit and he answers seriously
like he just answered seriously, right?
>> I've never spoken to Hutch, but I would
probably be good faith to most.
>> No, not like this. You are going you are
contorting so hard to be nice to Hassan
and to gain his crisis.
>> Okay, dude. Go ahead.
>> Well, no. I'm just saying it's not just
even if I were to grant that backwards
facing there's good criticisms. He says
I agree with you probably on where the
party needs to go. That's crazy.
>> Okay.
>> You agree? Isn't that crazy?
>> I think we should Why don't we listen?
>> No, wait. I I just want to just stop.
>> Wait, I just want to make sure we're
having a real conversation. I don't even
know if this is a conversation that this
is like Are we actually having uh next?
Yeah, you can.
>> Okay. Yeah. So, so like so so I just
want to know that we're having
conversation. Do you agree that this is
like a crazy thing to say?
>> No, not not in
>> not in context. Okay.
>> Not in the context of this conversation,
especially where we are in the
conversation right now.
>> All right.
>> Party as well, but I think there's
criticisms of the way that you you
approach that question or the way that
you talk about this. But
>> yeah. Yeah. If you want if you want to
know
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> kind of getting muddled in. But um yeah,
we're going to agree on a lot regarding
criticism of the Democratic party.
Probably where the Democratic party
needs to go will agree a lot. I'm very
disappointed with the Democratic party
as well.
>> You're right. There's a lot of hiding of
the really stupid rationale that they
don't say the common sense thing is like
I you could tell already. They'll say
things like yeah you uh you don't get
it. I don't I'm not going to explain
criticisms that question.
>> I don't know what to do for you man. If
you don't get it by now then I guess you
just like actually don't understand
>> the way you talk about this. But
>> yeah. Yeah. If you want if you want to
know what my position I feel like
>> you mean maybe you should just delete
your channel if you don't get it yet. If
you don't get it
>> at the very end there he said he
disagrees with a lot of the things he's
having in the conversation.
I I mean I I I get that, but I think
when you start by sort of having the
common ground as though we're part of
the same side, it kind of detracts a
little bit
>> doing that or just being like a g like a
you know being nice to somebody you're
talking to to for the first time.
>> I think he's creating a
>> like how you would be nice like you had
like cordial conversations with Rob
Noir.
>> Well, that's I think different. I think
my audience you think my audience
seriously is in any danger of falling to
Rob No's wits. My audience knows that
when I have a convers he's actually
doing a really good job. He's actually
doing the state machine. He's like
thought about this, like figured out how
he would argue this and then like I feel
I feel like he's got a legal pad
somewhere where he's like written down
how they're arguing this out so he can
figure out how to like argue back
against it, right? And he probably just
knows the other side of this dialogue
tree.
>> Oh, dude, that's very funny. What time
is the game at? What time is it? Or if I
have a conversation with like Myron
Games or something, my audience knows
that that's not good. Oh, it's
different. Obviously,
>> does your audience not know?
>> Are you really trying to compare? Are
you really trying to compare Rob No? No,
I'm just saying that you can have
cordial conversations. You're really
trying to
>> No, I'm trying to say that you can have
cordial conversations with people you
disagree vehemently with.
>> Well, if you know your audience isn't
gonna be [__] captured by Tanky Fox.
>> Do you think that for your audience?
>> Obviously not because I guard them
against them by criticizing people like
that.
>> Eastern [__]
>> Okay. But before this,
>> [__] me. I don't know. Maybe
>> I You think I support communism orism or
Marxist Londonism?
>> No. No. But I I like this uh your your
um your attitude and your demeanor now
is different. This is the first time I
think you've come into a stream, at
least the one that I've caught, where
you've been like this, been this hard.
Uh
>> I'm not going to answer that cuz it's
insulting.
>> This hard on communists.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm going way harder than mocker as you
agree that, right? Like before I said
that was hard, but this is the hardest
you've ever gone.
>> Dude, I Dude, it's so painful. It's so
painful. That's so painful.
>> Like you're like
>> I'm I'm really encouraged by this Pisco.
You seem like you're taking this really
seriously now and I'm so happy that
you're on our side. You're on the right
side. You got the right mentality, bro.
Bro, [groaning]
this is tough, man. This is tough,
>> right?
>> Huh? Well, I don't know that I'm putting
on a show. I think that I'm just doing
what any good liberal would do, which is
to call out people who are creating a
permission structure to interact with an
illiberal person who fundamentally wants
to destroy liberal democracy. And that's
what Adam is doing. He's he's creating a
permission structure for that.
>> Okay. But also, but again, so I guess
the only reason you do that with
right-wing people is because you don't
you're not worried.
>> Of course, obviously. Yes. Obviously.
>> Okay. So, it's only So, if if you were
in without an audience, you talk, you
would say this conversation is fine.
>> Yes. Because they're there's no danger
and my audience knows where I stand on
Rob No. They know that. And do you think
there's danger for Mockler's audience?
>> Um, actually yes. Actually, yes.
Actually, yes. Obviously.
>> Why do I think I think
>> because his audience is going to get the
impression that Hassan is just a little
bit to the left of Adam Mockler when
he's not. He's something else.
>> How do you know? Again, we're only we're
only for 30 40 seconds in.
>> Well, I just assume that that's how the
conversation is going to go.
>> Really? Why?
>> Because of how it started.
>> Okay.
>> Zar, and I think you're already pretty
familiar with my positions. I know that
like you you've probably heard me speak
on these issues for years and years at
this point, but um my primary goal,
especially in the interim, especially in
the short term, is the defeat of
fascism. I believe that the Republican
party is an illiberal party, a post-
liberal party, whatever you want to call
it. And I think unlike uh the uh
historic inception of fascism as a
revolutionary movement at a time when
liberalism was failing only 100 years
ago, this time that we have two liberal
parties in America, like as a political
theory, we have two liberal parties,
right? Like we say conservative,
whatever, but like technically the
Republicans are also a liberal uh party.
I warned about this the firstction in
this conversation. I think that was one
of the big things that Adam did wrong in
this conversation
>> as well. I warned about uh I warned
about the the protofascist nature of
Donald Trump. Um I thought that it was
important to make that distinction. I
didn't say that Trump like season one of
Donald Trump was fully fascist, but
season two of Donald Trump is. And I
think it's important to make that
distinction as well because like you can
see the difference, right? Like it there
were a lot of there was a lot of naked
corruption. A lot of things that were
going on in the first Trump
administration, but the second Trump
administration has been so brazen, so
obvious. And it's not like they've
hidden that reality at all, especially
when they were um when they were running
uh to to become the president, when they
were running during the
>> He's letting him yap more. This is like
when I talk to Counterpoints and it just
starts, right? And he just starts
yapping. All of a sudden, you [__]
you fall asleep. He's talking about
Warhammer 40k.
>> Yeah. Um uh in the 2024 election season.
So my primary goal is to defeat that
completely. And obviously I also want to
build socialism.
>> Right now, do you agree that Hassan has
a skin suit on?
>> 100%. Yeah, obviously. And Adam is not
exposing it. Instead, he's having a
polite conversation and letting Hassan
skinw walk as though he is one of us
when he's not.
>> So, I guess if Adam were to go on like
hammer in the same question three times
in a row and Hassan obviously didn't
answer. He Hassan tried to do a skin
suit dance and it kind of like blows up
in his face. You would consider that a
good strat by Adam, right?
>> Well, I think that you need to be super
aggressive with these people so it's
better than the strat he's doing. Is it
optimal?
>> Every single person needs to be
aggressive. There aren't even methods of
>> I think I think largely yes. I I think
we're at that point yet.
>> I don't think you believe that. I think
I think largely yes. [laughter]
>> I I actually I actually do think that
yeah
>> to ostracize these people need to be
like know that they can't be around us
at protest and I think that's great.
>> There's different ways you can do it.
Like you can have a guy
>> they're not welcome Chad standing over
top of somebody yelling at them and then
you can have the group of girls who like
laugh at that kid every single time and
destroy his self-esteem. Like there's
different ways to bring people down.
Um, this is making it some people are
better. This is making Adam is that much
of
>> it's like you're just listening to
somebody who's got like um
this person is like a populist in their
soul. They like they're like thinking
without any experience in this field.
They have a better idea of how to do
this than Pisco. They have a better idea
than people who have been operating in
this field. They've got a better idea
than anybody who's got experience
talking to other people. Anything like
that. I don't know what this guy does.
It seems like he's just like gonna take
other people's opinions and be like,
"Pisco, this is how you This is actually
how this could work.
He doesn't
It's rough, man. It's just rough
listening to somebody who doesn't know
what they're talking about come in with
this much confidence."
And I think they're like an older guy,
too. Like I think this guy's like 40.
Like he's like 30, 40. Having this level
of like overconfidence when you're like
a 20-year-old kind of makes sense. when
you're like that much older, you should
have a good idea that like you should
have way less
you should have way less of that like
weird overconfidence that like um
I'm not saying he's it's I'm not saying
there's anything wrong with being old.
I'm saying usually when you have
experience in the world, you calibrate
your confidence to like in in a much
more rational way. You've learned that
like oh when you're overconfident how it
sets you back and it just doesn't have
that. It's very weird to me. But like I
don't know if Adam's much of like a
hostile guy. I don't think they ever
seen him like that.
>> Then he shouldn't then he just shouldn't
do these debates. Then he just
>> No, he can be able He can do it in his
own different way. There's other ways to
put people down and make them look
stupid.
>> You think you think it's Adam's goal to
make look stupid?
>> Uh Pisco needs to ban this chatter. You
can mog Pisco by eating snacks on camera
right now. Pisco needs to ban this
chatter immediately. It's an unhinged
snarky chatter.
Unhinged snarky chatter right here.
Okay. Very snarky chatter over here. Ban
this person immediately.
I have a feeling I have a feeling this
person
would laugh
when somebody brings up the skull sent
to Ethan Klein. I have a feeling that
that's the kind of person this person
is. Absolutely disgusting.
>> I don't think that shows up
>> really. Yeah. Yeah.
>> I don't know. Maybe you're right.
>> To uh build a working- class movement.
And I don't think these two goals are at
odds with one another. I think both
historically, by the way, if for some
random reason the stream starts cutting
out, that's not my stream. If for if
this were to happen sometime, I don't
know because I haven't seen it yet, but
if this were to start happen, don't
worry. It's
>> It will likely be that I know for sure,
but it was 99% be the other stream.
>> Wait, what?
>> And also,
>> I'm saying if it starts cutting out, it
will I haven't seen this yet, but if it
were to,
>> it would be the stream. It wouldn't be
my streaming to you. Does that make
sense? If it were to do that.
>> Got it. Got it. Got it. Got it. Sorry.
Yeah. Took me a second. General, I
believe that uh the the evolution away
from the liberal system that we exist
under that is that is now failing for
the second time around and and making
way for fascism. The only solution out
of that is uh is to build a
working-class based organized socialist
movement. Um but yeah, those are my two
those are my two main points. Um if I
guess I want to ask you, do you think it
would be easier? Do you think it would
be meaningfully easier to build this
working-class socialist based movement
in a liberal society or an illiberal
society?
>> Oh, historically speaking, most likely
an illiberal society. At least
historically speaking, socialist and
communist movements have have
unfortunately
>> So I think that's good what Adam just
did right there. I think it's good that
he got he got Hassan to admit that in
order to for him to get where he wants
to go, we need to destroy liberalism.
And I think it's
>> because insane. Okay. So I I would agree
that's good. If he is able to follow up
and say that that's what Hassan wants
because unless he does that, then it
seems like all he's doing is getting
Hassan to yap about history. But if
Hassan is able
>> No, but that No,
>> no. I disagree. I think that Hassan
realizing that that's how you want to
get to his end goal. That's a that is a
step that is necessary to get to social.
>> He didn't say that. He said he said what
would be easier and he said historically
it would be illiberal. That's what he
said. He hasn't said that that's what
Hassan would want. That's the necessary
thing that Adam the funny thing is if he
well okay how about this if Hassan
doesn't give away to do it without
liberalism
or without removing liberalism and
getting into an illiberal
>> oh I forgot that the name Kosher Cathy
is literally yeah it's like loner box
snark in and of itself. I forgot that.
Yeah I for
>> society would you think that's good? All
right, let's see if he does. If he says
that he wants liberalism
>> and that he is a good socialist, Adam
needs to challenge him on that. Like
Hassan before has said that he supports
>> uh re-education camps. He has said
before he's a Marxist List,
>> uh gun to you. Thank you for the five
subs. You guys keep donating and I'm
like super not committed to serving for
the whole night, but thank you so much.
I appreciate it. I appreciate the app
letting it go unrebuted. What
preferences is liberal communism very
generous. Sorry. You guys have been very
generous tonight. I don't know how long
I'm going to stream for. I just feel
like um I've streamed a lot in the
recent past. I feel like this month my
streaming time is like way way way up.
Although maybe I took some nights off so
maybe not as much up as I thought.
>> What he wants
communism.
>> What I will define as success is if he
challenges Assan. If Hassan says
something like, "I would want
liberalism." But if he doesn't do that,
then he's failed. Okay, let's just make
sure about that.
>> Liberal society.
>> Oh, historically speaking, most likely
an illiberal society. At least
historically speaking, socialist and
communist movements have have
unfortunately only been successful.
>> Unfortunately, did you hear that?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Because Hassan doesn't
actually want to get he lives too comfy
of a life. That's why he said that.
>> Wait, I wouldn't be able to I won't be
able to get my Gucci.
>> Wait, so do you think that Hassan I'm
conf It's so crazy. I'm so confused.
Does does Assan want to end liberalism
because he's a Marist or does he want to
maintain it? He wants his Gucci back.
>> He understands that historically that is
how you get there.
>> But which does he want? Does he want the
end of liberalism?
>> We haven't gotten to that part of the
conversation yet.
>> No, I'm asking you based on your
impression.
>> I don't know. We haven't gotten there
yet. I got to listen to him talk.
>> Wait, why would you need to listen to
him? He's lying. He just likes to lie.
>> Why you Why are you laughing?
>> Hit play.
>> The material conditions have worsened. I
don't I don't want that to happen,
though. It could be
>> Yeah, right. He just said he doesn't
want ill liberalism.
>> Well, I Yeah, he doesn't want it to
happen again because then he won't be
able to charge his car.
>> Wait, so you agree that he doesn't want
the end of liberalism? That he's a
liberal?
>> No, I think he doesn't want to have to
go through the hard part to get to where
he wants to go.
>> He's not willing to suffer achieve his
end political goal.
>> Well, because maybe other people will
>> and he can motivate those people in a
way. Yeah, that can be seen as a threat.
>> But you don't actually think that he
wants to tear down the liberal order
because he thrives in it. No, he would
always be on the sidelines.
Interesting. [laughter]
>> Then why is he concerned about it
getting worse? Why is he concerned? Why
are you saying it's getting worse for
him? He doesn't want to give things up.
He's going to be on the sidelines
chilling anyway,
>> dude. Move to another country and keep
doing the thing.
>> Got it.
>> Sorry.
>> An appropriate thing to move towards. I
don't think that that's good for people.
I think it's very He thinks it's bad to
move from illiberalism. All right. Okay.
Well, I guess that's a good thing that
Adam got him to say.
>> Mhm. Yeah. violent and very deadly. I
don't want the material conditions to
deteriorate.
>> And you believe him? You think that he
he doesn't want the material conditions
to deteriorate?
>> Selfishly, yes.
>> Okay. But if you're asking me like
honestly from a historical perspective.
Oh, no.
>> I'm basically asking I'm basically
>> dude. Okay.
Hassan,
if Hassan gets the bit, he should
actually react to this conversation.
This conversation is actually you have
to be you have to be very intelligent to
understand this conversation. Not
really. said to be paying attention.
This is like actually Oh, this is this
is actually brutal to watch as somebody
who doesn't Oh, it's just it's actually
brutal to watch no matter what. It's
just brutal to watch, man.
>> Just asking if
>> Assan might not Han might not get like
>> this would be very funny for him to
watch.
>> But it's not even about that. They're
kind of standins. I don't even want to
concede who our nominees going to be two
years ahead. But I think it would be
there would be a meaningful difference
in building a you know pro labor
movement under a JD Vance presidency. It
would be much much harder versus a Gavin
Newsome presidency. I mean JD Vance his
entire career has been uh has been
trying to step on top of workers. He
wants to he project he endorsed project
2025 which literally wants to bring
>> he agrees
>> labor laws back to 1938. He's
fundamentally illiberal and doesn't want
to let you organize. I mean like a lack
of organization is part of not living in
a liberal society, right? They will
squash that. They will kill communists.
They will kill socialists. That's what
they did in other fascist societies.
They socialist and communists.
Meanwhile, Gavin Newsome, however
insufficient you may think he is, and
this is not an endorsement of Gavin
Newsome. I'm just trying to illustrate
my points of, you know, the different
realities we can enter. However
insufficient you think Davin Newsome is,
he would allow for
>> if this conversation were happening in
isolation, I would think this is like so
awesome from Adam, right?
>> Mhm. Why? Why? What do you like about
it?
>> Because if I knew that Hassan wasn't a
bad faith loser,
>> I would really enjoy that Adam and him
are like agreeing on some base
principles like liberalism, like that
Vance is worse than Newsome. I think
those are all like very effective
messages. If I felt his audience weren't
poisoned by Tanky and that he himself
weren't trying to embed himself to
poison our movement, then I would
obviously take issue with this stain
washing framing and the sane washing
permission structure that Adam is
imposing on all of us.
>> Okay.
>> A really strong labor move allow for you
guys to
>> I still like the way that Adam
approaches conversation. He could have
done better at it, but I don't think I
wouldn't necessarily say that that me
like what you just described
automatically makes it bad. Again, like
I said, there there are many different
ways you can approach conversations.
There are many different ways you can
clown on people. And Adam chose his own
way
>> or build bridges. I think he's building
a bridge with Assan. Do you agree?
>> No.
>> Well, at the end of the conversation
build a bridge, if anything, if a bridge
for his audience to come over to Adam's
side.
>> Oh, no. Because I suspect at the end of
this conversation based on
>> Wait. [clears throat] Oh, man.
Man, what am I thinking here? I just see
there's a lot of people doing work on
Twitter right now in just the gayest
ways draw attention just on the um like
I will actually like this tweet right
here.
>> Am I misunderstanding this? According to
Pisco, Destiny lied about Aaron being a
communist. Have I entered the Twilight
Zone? I'm pretty sure this
>> podcast a few
>> I'm pretty sure. Oh, did he post this?
Oh, maybe he posted this before Destiny
and Pisco talked. Destiny literally
conceded to Pisco on this. Is it like
literally a concession?
It's It's He lied about her being an ML
obviously and then he tried to justify
lying about her being an ML. Got blown
the out again. Good morning from Europe.
Welcome Snowy. I don't know how to say
your name. I'm sorry. I apologize.
>> Let's follow up
>> at the end and let's like get together
in LA. I assume that's what he'd say
based on how it started.
>> Maybe. And that would be building a
bridge, wouldn't it? If he did say that.
>> No, not necessarily. What if the next
conversation he comes in, he lulls
Hassan in with a false sense of security
and then he comes in and and brings the
hammer down. Wouldn't that be cinema
kino?
>> Yeah, but I just don't trust that he's
not just going to have another fest.
>> Why not, man? He's dude. He's on CNN.
He's good.
>> He's up there debating professionals. He
knows how to do it better than anyone.
>> Maybe. Maybe.
>> Listen, he is just a kid. But he's a
kid.
>> He's a kid, isn't he? 20.
>> Uh, let's see how I'm going to guess.
Um, 22. It's going to be like 19. I'm
going to be even more depressed. My guy
is 23 ream. [clears throat]
>> Well, Price's right. I didn't go over
>> practically a toddler.
>> Yeah, right. He doesn't even have a
fully developed brain yet.
>> Communicate with you guys. Do you
>> first of all, I don't even think you
guys I think you're a part of this as
well. I don't you're not against like
>> here. Do you mind? Sorry.
>> Sorry. He's like socialist and
communist. Meanwhile, Gavin Newsome,
however insufficient you may think he
is, and this is not an endorsement of
Gavin Newsome. I'm just trying to
illustrate my points of, you know, the
different realities we could enter.
However insufficient you think Gavin
Newsome is, he would allow for a really
strong labor movement. He would allow
for you guys to at least, you know,
organize and he would probably
communicate with you guys.
>> First of all, I don't even think you
guys I think you're a part of this as
well. I don't you're not against like
organizing labor movement.
>> He says, "Yeah."
>> Did you hear what that just happened
there? Wait, no. I don't want to go on.
>> Keep playing.
>> Say you're a part of it, too.
>> He's expressing solidarity with Assad.
You disagree?
>> Yes.
>> How How could you possibly disagree that
that wasn't an expression of solidarity
when Adam said yes to what Hassan just
said?
>> What do you mean by like what was he
agreeing in solidarity to? to um the
nature of um you know tamping down on
protest and labor rights different
realities we can enter that's what you
think is okay I I feel bad I am like
I'm like tired I I feel so bad for
leaving but I think I am going to call
it